mr. Skinner I just like to start by
asking what the provincial government is
doing to take advantage of this
provinces geographic proximity to
Greenland well there's been a fair bit
that has happened in the past we've had
three or four trade missions to
Greenland besides the one that i just
recently attended and there have been
worked on in telecommunications in terms
of internet and broadband infrastructure
there's been worked on in terms of boat
building there has been worked on in
terms of housing and prefab homes and
the main reason for the trip that I just
concluded was to introduce our offshore
industry companies to new nut oil and
the Greenland oil industry over there
and the minerals industry because of
some of the significant fines of oil and
gas hadn't found in greement recently
what was the reception like the
reception was very good there's there is
certainly a cultural link i'll call it
that they're their own Island people
there's 56,000 people and a huge land
mass so it's very sparsely populated a
lot like Newfoundland and Labrador only
a lot less people than new for land in
Labrador yeah so so there's there was a
bit of a link there I think I think we
have a lot in common but they also
recognized that we've had 25 years or so
30 years of an offshore oil in see
ourselves and we have technical
capabilities and we have competencies
that they can benefit from and so they
were very pleased that we contacted them
and that we went over a number of
companies came with us we had some
people from PF collins and from NOAA
itself Newland Archer Industries
Association we had people from Harvey's
we had Marine Institute attended with us
cougar helicopters so all of these
people came over and talked not about
their own companies it wasn't about
pitching your own services it was
talking about Newfoundland and Labrador
as a place to do business and
Newfoundland and Labrador visa V
offshore oil capability and capacity and
they were very receptive in Greenland
and very interested in what we had to
offer so receptive and so interested
that some of them will be coming back
again late this winter early in the
spring of 2011 know at this moment there
is no direct flights from
this country let alone this province to
Greenland what can we do about that yeah
we we were fortunate before we went we
tried to set up meetings with green land
area or Greenland and unfortunately the
people we wanted to see weren't
available at the time we left but when
we got there there were some people that
are coming from Denmark who are attached
with air greenland because they have a
great connection culturally and
otherwise with denmark and so we did get
to meet some people and it was a one of
our better meetings the information that
we were able to provide them about air
capacity and air access to Newfoundland
and Labrador and strategically
geographically where were located
relative to the north and relative to
other major markets was something they
weren't aware of and so they were very
interested in coming here and as I
indicated earlier ear agreement for
instance will be here and I expect
februari marriage to follow up I've
shipped them off some information I
contacted our local airport authority
our local terror provincial department
of business I gathered up some
information to send them about our
capabilities of airports the kinds of
connections we have the numbers of
passengers we have where those
passengers go and I also did a bit of
research myself in terms of how much
business were currently doing in
Greenland that could be beneficial to an
ear link so for instance I happen to
have a friend who I ran into in nook the
capital of Greenland while I was there
and he's a fisherman not a fishing boat
and when I ran into my ass the money was
doing there and he told me that he was
over with this fishing boat and they do
a crew change every 20 days and there's
a 35 or 40 of them and there are a
number of boats he told mean a number of
different companies so when I came back
to Newfoundland and Labrador I
approached his company and he gave me
some information that was beneficial to
air greenland and he also put me in
touch with other companies that would
use an airlink if it was available right
now they had to make other flight
accommodations and his two or three sort
of ups and downs before they get to
where they need to go to and having it
directly from st. John's or from
somewhere in Newfoundland and Labrador
would be a big advantage for them from
goose bay from goose pate for instance
and Labrador would be a perfect
opportunity we actually flew out of
goose bay over to no canned it's a very
short flight a beautiful flight cohen
in there and a lot closer than I
realized it was and so I you know I
think there's all kinds of reasons why
we can be doing business with Greenland
and I think the important thing about
our mission was because it was a
government and a business mission they
got to talk to business people about how
we do business here they also got to
talk to government about a regulatory
regime at our offshore oil industry and
they were very interested in that
interested enough as I said that they're
going to come back I'm going to have
more meetings with them since we want
their business why not have one of our
Airlines provincial Airlines or air
Labrador or somebody look at doing those
flights and is that a possibility yeah
it certainly is a possibility we think
that it's it's got to be reciprocal in
terms of you know both have to benefit
and one of the things that we were
hoping to do was was have ear Greenland
come here to give us more access to the
European market as well because they do
fly into the European market and we felt
that that would be a good link for us so
it opened up more opportunities for us
it wasn't just getting the Greenland we
wanted to get the Greenland yes but we
also wanted to open up other markets in
England and Ireland and other
Scandinavian countries for other export
opportunities for some of our other
businesses what else has to be done to
ensure that new felan companies and
labrador companies benefit from what is
surely going to be a natural resources
boom in Greenland in the coming years
well your coy corrector is going to be a
boom there and it is going to be related
to natural resources and I think the
immediate potential beneficiaries can be
our service and supply companies in the
offshore oil and gas industry and and
they're aware of each other I mean the
new nut oil in Greenland which is there
a sort of national oil company we're
quite familiar with some of our players
and quite familiar with their
capabilities they're currently being
serviced from Aberdeen and it's longer
distance it's more expensive and they're
looking at other alternatives and they
see newfoundland and labrador's a
service-based as being much more
practical for them and much less
expensive but i also think there's a lot
of companies that can feed into that
supply chain from a service basis and
and from just a building of
infrastructure one of the things that
Greenland is going to have to grapple
with when this boom occurs is there
isn't infrastructure available Durant
Rose rent roads to rent houses they
don't have the adequate medical
facilities
schools and all those kinds of things so
they have schools and hospitals I'm not
saying don't have them but they don't
have them to the capacity that they
would need with an influx of people with
an influx of people coming to work and
live there so they're going to need
people on the ground they're going to
need to build infrastructure for that
while we were there we saw apartment
buildings going up four or five
six-story apartment buildings they're
getting ready for it and so some of it
will happen on the ground in Greenland
but some of it I think can also happened
in Labrador and could for instance
happen in happy valley-goose Bay because
of the short ride that should have to
take on a plane you could house or stage
what you need to stage in happy
valley-goose Bay and then just pop the
people across a short flight an hour and
a half or so and they're in Greenland
they could be working so who initiates
that is that your government that's
going to build the infrastructure to
make happy valley-goose Bay an
attractive option for good for Greenland
well it's it's going to be right now
it's been initiated by us as a
provincial government and when I was
minister of innovation trade rural
development I traveled with the Minister
of Natural Resources who's now premier
Dunderdale so I happen to follow in her
footsteps here that's a nice linkage for
me I'll work with the current Minister
of innovation trade royal development
and I'm also currently working with the
minister of business because he's
responsible for outside investment and
attraction and we collectively will work
with the people in Greenland make sure
that we understand that we you know we
both share a similar vision of how we
want to do things and it's very early
stages and fairness right now we're just
trying to get them to come back meet
with us talk to them about the plans
that we think we we can put together
some of the business will do and the
Rome they don't need government some of
this is going to be driven by a business
necessity but there are going to have to
be infrastructure and social plans put
in place by the government to Greenland
and the government to new flame Labrador
I believe to be able to service what's
going to happen agreement so it's it
there's a whole bunch of things
happening at once it's not sort of
linear it's a whole bunch of things
happening at once in parallel and some
of them will move faster than others
simply because of the demands of the
business but we feel we've opened up a
good dialogue I met with a number of
ministers while I was there myself from
premiered under Dale met with premier
Kleist over there and and we believe
that they're very interested and very
aware of the capabilities new Flambeau
Labrador and that's why they're going to
come back and have further chats here
and see
what we have to offer that we invited
them back not so much to talk to them
but to show them what we have we felt it
was important that they see our
University they see our Marine Institute
see our offshore supply service areas
see the infrastructure we have they need
to know the capabilities we have see the
runways and happy valley-goose Bay and
so on how short a distance it is they
need to be made aware of that they
weren't aware of that when we went over
the also mean so many of the oil
companies that operate here are starting
to explore in the baffin island baffin
bay area and it seems to me that if we
want to supply them i ship we're going
to need another harbor or another port
is this something that you've thought
about well there's been lots of
discussions about other ports you know
the port of st. John's has been looking
at some expansion and some some
reconfiguration you fresh water to what
it's doing some of it is happening in
our ginger there are people in our gen
charged inches a huge deep ice water ice
free port deepwater port the port of
Corner Brook even though that's on the
other side of the islands it's a very
good port for transshipment of a lot of
materials so we've got options and also
the port of happy valley-goose Bay
there's you know there's opportunities
there so the question now becomes one of
as we engage with the people from
Greenland to find out what their needs
are and what what we believe our needs
are in terms of servicing them where is
it best to do it from and that will be
driven by governments in both
jurisdictions it will be driven by
businesses and it will be driven in a
lot of cases by who's able to ramp up
quickly enough to be able to do it which
pork for instance is able to give get
off the ground earlier and that'll be
you know that will be a competitive
process because I mean someone like me
the potential is so huge over there but
I wonder so who starts tapping into it
how do you get get ensure that that we
get that piece of action well I guess
there's no certainties with that I mean
as I indicated earlier they are being
serviced by other jurisdictions right
now they are looking though they
understand that there are other options
out there Cairn Energy says it's the
competitive you know it's having that
competitive edge so how do we ensure
that we have that competitive
what do we have to do well I think the
first thing we needed to do was make
them aware of our capabilities they did
not have an understanding of how much we
had to offer they knew generally
speaking where we were they know
generally speaking we were involved in
the offshore oil industry they knew we
had some regulatory regimes but until we
got over there and talk to them in
detail there were many times when they
went to this is very informative we
didn't understand you were so fair
advanced and because they're just
starting they literally just discovered
there where we were in 1980 Bragman sake
you know that's that's where there too
and so there's a lot for them to learn
but we've got a lot of stuff already in
place that we can help them with so
having them come here and having them
see what we've got we believe will be
sort of the stamp that will make all of
this happen they'll understand then what
we can do for them when is it you're
expecting them here I expect in February
marriage okay good they should be here
now we have the fiber optic cable so
what how do we build on that and and how
did that come to be anyway well the the
fiber optic cable is out in Milton out
in the Clarenville area goes back under
see through to Greenland I actually I
haven't seen the the station here in
Milton yet but I did see the station in
Greenland and I did get him to open up
the the big box when we walked into the
room it's just a room with a bunch of
wires but the main cable that came in
from the ocean I did manage to put my
hand on it and I said that someday I'll
get back to Milton and be able to put my
hand on the other end of it but that
came about a liar a lot of that was
driven by Greenland and academic
institutions by more University who are
linking together researchers who are
linking together and they wanted to have
a link to North America they already had
a link to Europe but they wanted to be
able to have that redundancy to be able
to have something happened to the
European link to be able to go a
different way to be able to get back
into North American back through Europe
and so they decided that they'd come
into a new client Labrador to do that
because we were the closest place and so
they spent i believe it was around three
four million dollars to to bring that
line over that fiber optic line
underwater and build a station in Milton
that houses it may have a person out
there that maintains it looks after and
all that kind of thing and so you know
the that's now done wonders for the
university community in terms of the
capability and
the amount of data and the amount of
information that can be put through that
line has increased you know ten or a
hundred fold so it's done a lot that way
in terms of speeding up how to
researchers are using the information
but what it also does is there are
private companies now that are looking
at that to see other ways they can tap
into Greenland in terms of opportunities
for them with data services with with
redundancy you know companies that need
to have backup plan should something go
wrong with the powers last or if there's
an emergency where would they store
their data how would that day to be able
to be utilized if an emergency occurred
and we potentially could be a site for
that and that was an important I guess
opening for a relationship with
Greenland is it do you mean how how
would you you know characterize that in
terms of the importance of building a
closer relationship well I think what it
did was a build some trust and the sense
i got when i went to and I was very
curious when I went as minister to find
out how we would be perceived I did want
to be perceived as coming in and trying
to take something from them and we
talked about that as a mission before we
left I talked about that with the the
company's I asked them to come into my
office and we had a chatter so we're not
going to over there to take anything
we're going over there to let them know
what our capabilities are and if they
feel there's something they we can do
for them we'll ask them about that and
if we feel there's something we might be
able to do will offer it up to them but
I don't want us gone in to feel like
we're going to take something from them
so we went through with the approach of
you know we've we've done a lot of what
you people now we're going to have to go
through and we think we can offer you
something and we'd like you to come and
see what it is we could offer and so the
Greenland piece because we did discuss
and had discussed some of that
telecommunications line that particular
piece of business that we had done had
given us some trust with them for lack
of a better word it they had confidence
that we were willing to work with them
to their benefit as much as to our
benefit and I think that sort of that
helped soften some things for so when we
went into government to the offices when
went in the premier's office when we
went in the boardrooms and some of their
major companies you know telegram
lenders shipping lines their oil
companies their mining companies there
was an understanding that these were
friends coming that's how I felt I felt
like they were welcoming a friend and it
wasn't just purely business it was a
little bit softer than that and I felt
it was
was very good to have an exchange of
information I felt very comfortable in
all the meetings I was in I felt very
comfortable with our presentations and
it was a dialogue like you and I are
having now it wasn't just a presentation
it really was a conversation how would
you compare the potential for jobs that
Greenland has four Newfoundlanders with
Fort McMurray well at this stage I
certainly think that Greenland is in
very early stages and you know there are
Greenland wants to see Greenlandic
people benefit they have you know a
large population as I said 56,000 people
but they have a population and a lot of
their population is not working they
used to be a Fisher people for the most
part that was their main economy we know
what's happened with the fisheries it's
affected them over there so they'd like
to transition some of their people from
fishing into the oil and gas and an
offshore oil and gas supply service
industry so I think their first
priorities let's see what we can do to
skill up and to to make our own people
available to work in this industry and
how we as people who may be going in
there to offer services can help them
with that then secondary to that will be
other people going into work there will
be opportunities the quantity I'm not
prepared at this point nor would I have
any particular information to be able to
put on it but the opportunity is
certainly there and I think it's a large
opportunity as biggest sport with Marie
I'm not sure if it would be that big
that's you know it's hard for me to say
at this point because they don't have
you know as I indicated there are
infrastructure issues I don't know how
fast they're going to want to move this
development for it but on how fast are
going to be in terms of creating the
infrastructure after gonna need they may
not develop it as fast as we did or as
other jurisdictions have done they're
taking their time to their credits are
taking their time and they're doing it
slowly and they're making sure that they
lay a good firm foundation before they
get too far along and I commend them for
that I think that's what they should be
doing in terms of educational
opportunities it was very clear that
they want training what what steps have
you taken since you got back or has the
government taken since it got back to
see if our educational institutions here
could offer that training you know
there's no doubt that there's great
interest in educational opportunities
they were very very interested in the
fact that we had the Marine Institute
along the representative from the Marine
Institute
had some great conversations and did
some good presentations with people they
still do a fair bit of work underwater
they're interested in training for
people on the water whether it be
fishing or offshore oil and gas whatever
it may be they're very interested in
safety they're very interested in making
sure that their workers are safe and the
Marine Institute do a lot of that so one
of the minister's that we actually met
with her husband was a captain on a
fishing vessel and she brought him to a
supper meeting to talk but to
representative from the Marine Institute
so they could share some information and
they will be coming over to follow up
with the Marines though and what they
might be able to do for them so there I
think there's a lot of opportunity there
and expansion would we have to expand to
accommodate the new students etc know
what we discussed with them initially is
that the Marine Institute is able to be
able to go to them and currently does
i'll call it outreach training and is
set up to be able to do that so the
Marine Institute is currently doing that
a lot of places not only in Canada but
around the world and the initial
conversations or that we would go there
and do the training on their sites
they'd have to provide the sites and
some of the infrastructure but we would
provide the expertise in the curriculum
and those kinds of things right now
there's a moratorium on Arctic drilling
in Canada deepwater drilling we're close
to baffin baffin bay that whole region
where they are exploring for oil is that
some dulce canada-newfoundland that
Labradors industry moving there is that
is that does that potential for this
province in terms of where the industry
you know will move or may want to move I
mean I think there are a lot of options
that are available to them my sense and
I've you know I've been here in this
portfolio for a week now but my sense
based upon my trip with the
representatives of Noah is that they see
Greenland is being somewhere that's the
next hibernia for them for lack of a
better word and I think there's a great
interest and I think they'll be going
there and I think that would be going
there strong we're too after that who
knows you know I think that will be
driven by the company's more solid by
governments the companies will determine
where they feel the best bang for their
buck will be and they'll move to that
migrate towards that and right now I
think Greenland is certainly something
that they see is a prime opportunity is
there anything that you need the federal
government's cooperation with in order
to continue to build on this
relationship
green line no we haven't had any
instance incident yet or incidences of
where we would need to engage with the
federal government I mean it's certainly
something that as I in my role now as
Minister of Natural Resources engage
with my federal and provincial
counterparts I'll talk more about it
because I think there's opportunities
there for other you know people to other
parts of Canada be able to engage in and
if there's ways that we might be able to
partner with the federal government or
other Atlantic provinces in particular
I'd be more than open to try to do that
I think we need to do more of that sort
of regional cooperation because when you
get outside of your own jurisdiction and
you're competing in the world we're
competing against some fairly large
entities and you know be they companies
or be their countries and sometimes
Newfoundland and Labrador would be well
served to be joined with some of the
other Atlantic provinces or with the
government to Canada and we do that in
other places you know we joined together
when we've gone on trade missions to
present ourselves as a region as opposed
to a province so if there are
opportunities for that we'd explore
those but right now I don't see that as
being something that's on the immediate
need to conclude what is the potential
of Greenland I think the biggest
potential in Greenland right now is in
the archer oil and gas and and the
opportunity to help them develop
infrastructure to be able to supply and
service that and by infrastructure I
don't just mean the rigs and the the you
know the chemicals and stuff that they
would need I'm talking housing on
talking roads I'm talking education
training all of those things are going
to be needed and I would one of the good
things i should mention this one of the
good things that i saw is that Greenland
has no would everything that they have
in Greenland is imported we've had some
you know closures here with our Mills
we've lost the ability of lost grand
falls-windsor in terms of our meals we
have an opportunity for export of not
just raw product lamb talk and finish
product things like furniture all the
furniture that they have their it's all
imported houses everything over there
has to be brought in so there's a
tremendous opportunity for that kind of
thing and we've you know we've engaged
back here to try and prepare when they
come to to show them the capabilities in
the capacity we have here and how we may
be able to get our product over to them
and I think they're going to be very
interested when you get here in seeing
why they should engage with
as much as we're trying to engage with
them the greenland norris apparently
used to cut wood in labrador brought it
back and regards that historical
connection well we're going to continue
that connection hopefully all right
thank you very much thank you